hurt what type of coffee maker
well it's a not not really a
too fancy one uh but i like it
okay this is the question question
answers oh he said
a the first very first q a uh all right
all right um so it's a pleasure
have shown uh
introducing us to all the wonders of
what control theory can do
together with ariel uh so shown
stage is yours all right well i've been
looking forward to this for a while
um uh so uh yeah i'm sean mine at the
university of florida
and um this is um
about 45 minutes for my house it's
vanity springs
and um that and that's a little manatee
that you'll find swimming around in the
springs in the winter time
to stay warm and you can see here that
france doesn't have any manatees
so i had to substitute something
so when when this this topic came up
with giving this
this little short course you know i was
obviously
very excited and eager and also
i'd seen uh richard murray from caltech
give a crash course in control
at the 2018
um real-time decision-making program
at uh at berkeley
and we need our t-shirts the logo is so
cool we need t-shirts um
and he did such a beautiful job of sort
of of
explaining the field of control it was
really an inspiration
and so that's why i asked you all to
please
watch his video in advance so i'm sort
of motivated in part by his
his tutorial and then i'm going to give
some history
of the subject and and maybe maybe ideas
that can help
uh rl and also sort of a roadmap of the
lectures to go
okay uh lots of people to thank
me in particular um vivek
barcar wearing a mask before it was cool
um i started because of ben van roy's
thesis
and and my first sabbatical vivek
i got into reinforcement learnings that
was back in the late 90s
um and then aditya devraj who just
graduated is now a postdoc at berkeley
he dragged me kicking and screaming back
into the area
three years ago and he got his phd in
the area
and anabushitch has been a longtime
collaborator
and inspiration um and the same goes for
prashant mehta and eric moline
and there's too many people to list i
mean my advisor was such an
incredible peter kane's inspiration as a
grad student
and forget i won't go through all these
people but some of these people on this
list
are people inspired because their work
and other people because of um
collaborations and um yeah
okay so um here's a quick uh
outline i won't go through it um
jess i will i will mention this okay so
again
i said it's a thousand times in discord
uh
it's really valuable to look at this
overview of richard murray
he gives a nice overview of sort of
control the
philosophy um then there's two there's a
tutorial i gave at
um at berkeley two years ago and
it takes it sort of cut you know
discusses my view of the stochastic side
of things
um and and and and
really starts off with the premise of
eric yesterday
that asymptotic theory shouldn't be
ignored it's really
really valuable for insight and
sometimes it's surprising how it works
and i feel like that's that's when it
says hidden theory that's all i meant
was that asymptotic theory is super
valuable
and really crisp and clean and pretty so
if you want to know more see that or
wait until my book comes out next year
so kova did one favor for me it said
what the hell i might as well do it
and i spent the whole summer instead of
having fun in france
i i i spent my time writing these
lecture notes
for this presentation those five
chapters
okay um and then you know um
there's other resources here okay so
some apologies to begin with
pi is now 3.14
and it's not a policy because a pie is
an invariant measure
i'm sorry it just always will be for me
it will never be a policy i can't do it
so i will use fee for feedback or i'll
put a little tilt on
top for a randomized policy that's
apology number one
um control engineers minimize cost
we never receive any rewards for it it's
just
one of the curses of the field and so i
have an
input space instead of an action space
and i'm minimizing cost and not
maximizing reward
this it's a curse of being a control
engineer
and finally i'm not needing to be rude
or
offensive or whatever i will sometimes
be critical
and it's just an opinion and so please
don't be offended uh
i don't have all the answers so often
somebody's being critical of something
the perception is that they're arrogant
and they know all the answers say they
know the answers i don't have all the
answers
there's some things that i think maybe
are a mistake
and it's just an opinion and my opinion
could be stupid
let's investigate okay all right so this
won't be as provocative as i thought i
might make it
because i do have some strong opinions
as some of you know um but i will
i will shake things a bit all right
all right so let's go through with some
background so this is this is what
you'll get if you go to wikipedia and
look up reinforcement learning
all right and so my first so this this
is probably
the most adversarial
um part of my lectures of the entire day
i won't read this out for you you know i
mean well maybe i will reinforcement
learning is an area of machine learning
yes
concerned with how software agents ought
to take actions in an environment
to maximize some notion of community
reward
not bad but this thing
this thing please let's make it a task
of this
this semester to edit this chart
all right i mean why on earth
is sarsa always in a discreet action
state space i mean
so let's fix wikipedia okay that's
that's a challenge for the boot
for the for the semester but
like this is some new addition to
wikipedia i've never seen this uh
version of it it's the standard page of
wikipedia
yeah yeah this is what it looked like in
july
oh yeah i see it now wow okay yeah
yeah it's it's really wacky you know it
changes every year
you should have seen the markov chain
definition five years ago now it's the
best
it's the best definition but five years
ago was just laughable
um and so you know examples
people talk about is stock trading
people have been selling
reinforcement learning to wall street
forever and wall street actually
is kind of pissed off at rl i mean for
reasons that we could discuss autonomous
cars small buildings smart cities
and you know what the hell are we
talking about
because i forgot i mean
look what i highlighted
everything is model free so the the
claim is that if it's not
if it's not model free it's not rl
it's just and the thing is that
trading stocks driving cars managing the
grid anyone who's actually tried to code
rl
knows how long it takes by the time
my algorithm is converged there will be
a whole new economy
you know there'll be a whole new
political party in power
so you know we know about craft flash
crashes and all of that
we know about the problems of autonomous
cars
we're not going to be learning as we
drive
you know um and so we have to have a lot
more humility
and i'm not i'm not yelling at rl
every field has this problem of
overselling and
there's nobody who did who made a bigger
mistake in the controls community
you know they oversold their stuff in
the 80s and they paid for it
and neural networks too right there was
a lot of overselling
of neural networks back in the 70s and
they it
really shut down the research area for a
while just because of
of of a very narrow definition of the
subject
so let's just all agree that rl is a
very very
young subject you know even though it's
it's been around a long time
um and it's it's evolving around with
statistics and control and all that
all right okay so how did control get it
wrong
so the the there was incredible
uh excitement about adaptive control
back in the 80s
and in 70s and 80s and this is a
this is from a really nice um i should
have put this in the
bibliography um tutorial by
eric yitzy at cmu and
uh and basically it's you know some of
the reports about this
beautiful uh uh um
[Music]
airplane was that you don't need a model
and it says here it
the pilot was unburdened model free
you know um you know the airplane was
stable any dynamic pressure any angle of
attack
i think it says somewhere that yeah the
pilot could spend time cross-checking
flight instructions
you know making a cappuccino so
you know so this is a sort of
overselling
of something very very delicate and
here's what happened
is that it didn't work you know it
basically
there was high gain there was parameter
bursting
it was not robust that you know wind-up
means the parameters
would grow because of integration and
wham you know kill the pilot
you know it it just went crazy and
crashed
um and so this setback
adaptive control decades it just
completely
and of course it killed a pilot you know
that's gone you know i i
i'm so i'm sad about that but but
you know let's not talk about that let's
talk about the fact that
a lack of attention a lack of humility
kill the pilot
and kill the field in a way so adaptive
control
continued onwards but only in very very
controlled
situations chemical engineering paper
manufacture
things like that and i bet it could have
done a lot more if people have been a
bit more conservative
you know and what happened is that
robust control took over the control
area
in the 90s and 2000s which was a very
conservative field they did beautiful
science people at berkeley
with some of the pioneers there i was at
mcgill at the time where george sames
was he was absolutely
astonishing hero but incredibly
conservative so if you
even talked about adaptive control he'd
leave the room um
so there's a conservativeism in every
field and sometimes people get over
excited and they make
they make big mistakes you know so let's
keep this in mind you know we're gonna
have to
i i'm sure you need a model to somehow
restrict the search space and
gets to get stability guarantees of some
sort more intuition
there's going to be some in applications
like flight control autonomous vehicles
medical applications i suspect at least
for the next 20 years
there'll be a hybrid between model-free
and model-based approaches
all right so those are fighting words to
some people
and it's my opinion it's not you know i
don't have all the answers
all right so what control can offer so
this was me drunk in zurich walking home
from a party dth
and trying to find my way home that's uh
this is uh
some of you might recognize this since
eric i don't know
um so this is basically stolen from uh
richard murray's tutorial
um and so you know this is just like
right out of a reinforcement learning
talk you know bike sharing
airplanes the pancreas you know i mean
artificial pancreas
on wall street i've been i was involved
in semiconductor manufacturing like
scheduling problems
all these things are the process um
and we have inputs or actions you know
which you all know about uh this could
be throttle or wheel position in a car
and then we have measurements and the
measurements are noisy you know
so the measurements could be the speed
and position of the car and so forth
okay so that's lecture one in the
control course
for undergraduates at senior level
um and this is a screenshot from richard
murray's talk
um so basically when you talk about the
specifications
there's a whole huge list you know
there there is all sorts of transient
things there's something called a step
response that
people look at it's just it's just a
convention of if i
put in a step change to an input or a
step change disturbance
how does it the the system respond how
long does it take to recover
questions like that these transient
issues uh these things you know called
rise time how long does it take to
recover overshoot
all these things you know um and
and then basically the steady state
responses to disturbance
and a lot of is based on frequency
response
which blows the mind of every young
control student
why would you look at the frequency
response of an
automobile if you wanted to learn how to
control it
can you imagine getting into a car and
pushing this all down letting go push it
down at sine wave
all right that's one frequency now do it
really slowly down for five minutes
up for five minutes down for five
minutes now do a megahertz
and see how the car responds now you
know if you move the throttle fast
the car doesn't respond you do it slowly
the car slows up speeds down slows up
speeds down
i you know i mean yes a speed stop slows
down
that is how you design a cruise control
it's no frequency response so
that's why students go what the hell why
what am i doing here because i think
it's such an abstraction
and yet it is the 99 of control systems
are
designed based on frequency response and
these are just random plots
from from um from presentations
um you know basically looking at
response to disturbance or initial
condition
and frequency response of you know that
doesn't matter what that is
but there are other things too you know
there are hard constraints you can't
violate
and there's sort of there's you know and
both of the safetyness and liveness of
things that come out of
just making sure that things are
constrained and safe
all right now the first thing you would
do
if you have a really good model is just
invert
so there's something you care about z it
could be some big vector of things you
care about
and there's some operators say um
g so it doesn't have to be a linear
system just have to be transfer function
there's some operator that takes
inputs to things you care about and you
might not measure them
and you just invert all right and that's
what's known as open loop control
and richard murray said to my surprise
if you can do it do it
which is pretty bold statement i don't
know if people normally do that
um i think what he really meant
is you come up with a sort of a
regularized
inverse might be okay
you know you don't really just invert
all right the frequency domain is one
way of defining that regularization that
you don't try to invert high frequencies
you just do it in moderate frequencies
all right
and classical control is all about that
all of classical control is this
you you there's a thing you care about
z but you can't observe it so you come
with an observer
and then you define these are transfer
functions h and g but just think of the
operators if you don't know what that
means
so it's something that you have an
estimate of what you care about
and you transform it in some sense
and again and this is this depends on
the entire history of your
of your measurements of your estimates
um and you have another operator the
entire history of your observations y
and you choose it to get an approximate
inverse and it really is a
regularization
because you designed this to basically
invert in a certain frequency range
and forget about the rest that's causal
control
done and all of class will control the
first semester course
is about how to design the observer how
to design age and how to design gc and
justify it all
that's the entire entire course right
yeah
sean may i ask a question
so if you want to relate this to
reinforcement learning
how would you explain what's the
relationship uh
between the control task that is being
created here
versus the control task that
reinforcement learning
traditionally with cancer you know with
reward functions or cost functions if
you wish yeah
so i'm gonna i'm gonna do that in a
moment
okay good because people are wondering
about this
yeah i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure well so
basically i can say this that
one justification
is lqr
can i do this yeah so basically minimize
the sum k equals zero to infinity
of c of x k not z
yeah z k
yeah yeah okay so what i was thinking
about that
so the the control task that you're for
presenting
uh at the very high level
is like really this inverse view of
point like point of view that
you want to design the inputs maybe
using
feedback in such a way that something
desired happens but in
all possible ways like yeah that is like
all possible behaviors
and and you want it's a full inverse
almost like what what is going on
uh if we look at this diagram as an
input output
uh diagram right so so that is that
that's the
the task specification and then
um and then the you that's that's what
you design if you could invert you would
invert but
uh and in relation to reinforcement
learning
uh reinforcement learning kind of like
just reduces this to this
one-dimensional reward signal thing but
here you're talking about you know like
the full inverse of the system if you
wish
right well i guess i just realized
it's on the next slide okay right
it's right there yeah yeah
where how
so so that's the thing that's a mistake
they make
in classical control when they teach
students
they never tell them
so that was one big point richard murray
made his presentation
you know how did this come from what is
the desire
you know and so basically you have some
intuition
that you know if somebody hits the
accelerator they want to get to a
certain speed but not too fast
and so you cook something up but my next
slide will answer the question
all right so so this is causal control
so obviously i'm going to go a little
bit further
and then this so next slide please
okay um so
um oh wait wait wait i mean forget this
yeah oh yeah but i will say this so
again i didn't say this i left something
out
i mean again it's all model based
you know um and
you have a disturbance this is real
wind hitting the airplane you have noise
that's not real it's your sensors have
noise
and also you model uncertainty in the
process
through another feedback loop and you
assume that these all in some bounded
class
you know so that's that's this there's a
robustness there's a huge part of it
and you make sure that your solution is
going to work regardless
of you know what um
of delta n and d and now i can it's this
slide now next slide
um yeah let me copy and paste that
probably shouldn't do this because i
have a lot to say but
i forgot that i had a few things here so
just you remember this because it's
really important um so this is exactly
what
what shabbat was was sort of getting at
and i was trying to make
is that so my my task is to drive from
here
across to the farmer's market and
is this my feedback system right so
as i decide to drive across town i will
create
this desired signal you know
i will create this thing
my z desired well hey i'm going to get
in my car
turn it on drive around to avoid the
demonstrations downtown
and then go around and do this and that
there's a whole
the whole task of coming up with z
desired is a planning process in advance
and um and which is which is often
ignored
well it is always ignored in a classical
control course
um so this whole thing of just reacting
doing
everything in real time is just a small
part of the puzzle
and it there's this trajectory
generation which is creating
something more general like this this
xraf
with which generates a z-graph
it's sort of the same concept
basically based on on your desires
you're going to come up with some
trajectories
that's often called feed forward
and then you're going to have this
reactive part as well which is based on
typically state feedback
there's an observer that gets more than
the z that i talked about before but in
an entire state um and so
you've got this incredible big extra
layer
and typically every one of these yellow
boxes
is built around mpc model predictive
control
which is the same as receiving horizon
control
and really it's a misnomer to call this
speed forward
because it's really what was happening
is this
in this case two time skills for control
there's the reactive thing where i'm
driving
speed up push down turn the wheel
there's a feedback loop continuously
like that
and this is trajectory generation where
there's also feedback
because i plan to drive a void downtown
but then the road was shut down i have
to reoptimize you continuously
update in this trajectory generation so
it's a slow time scale for control
and a fast time scale so there's what
richard murray called reactive the
trajectory generation is just a slower
time scale
all right and so there you see a
connection with mp
with rl that's more clear i think okay
all right um
let's see i'll say i want to say that
i think that i okay so you can see that
there's an rl connection
but let's not go there yet let's see a
few more things
so adaptive control has exactly the same
obsessions
as as we do you know i haven't worked
adaptive control since forever
um but they want to do this they want to
solve this
optimization problem but maybe with only
partial model information
and um and the way it's defined
um in in for example max zuginski's
course which he's teaching this semester
this is for the first page of his
his lecture notes um which is quite
which is quite fun
um the definition is almost exactly the
same as rl you know
i'd like to control a system reach a
goal without exact knowledge of the
system
that's a perfectly valid definition of
rl um
and the thing is an example would be a
model an mdp model or a linear system of
bounded dimension
but you assume those things for analysis
everyone knows that when you're done you
the real world doesn't satisfy those
assumptions
that's why we're obsessed with
robustness okay so um
so the the root the adaptive control and
rl
have really essentially identical goals
i would say and again i know that's
fighting words to some of you
but that's my opinion okay
um i think that rl you know in real life
there'll be some partial model knowledge
which goes into the architecture okay
just like adaptive control
i think adaptive control is more model
based than rl that's for sure
um and i'm not going to go through every
bit of this except
a common tool is this od method that
term was from leonard young but it's
other
the stochastic approximation method of
robinson monroe
and so two incredible heroes johnson
cyclist and michael jordan
um simultaneously in 1994
pointed out the connection between
watkins q learning
and stochastic approximation and um
you know and and and stochastic
approximation was a foundation
of adaptive control forever and you know
i mean forever
i can't give you the first uh papers but
this is a this is an old paper from the
70s by linda young
and i'm going to come back to it because
i think he went backwards i think
leonard i love him but i think he made a
mistake in this paper
having equation one saying this is a
standard algorithm yeah
i'll get back to it this is this is the
the punch line will come later
okay all right so um so there's common
analytical routes as well as common
goals
okay so boy time flies when you're
having fun
um i'm gonna i'm not gonna go through
all of this
i'm going to later on you know i'm going
to talk about
richard sutton's wonderful
car problem trying to get to the top of
a car efficiently
and there's a value function basically
i'd like to look at the total cost
until i reach my goal um
and by the way there's an exercise for
all of you
why is the state position in velocity
it doesn't have to be you know the state
is something we manufacture
depending on our goals that's true in
classical control and an oral
but we'll take that um and
this example is very swim similar to
swinging up a pendulum
for which is a lot of really cool tricks
in the control community so
i recommend this reference by astrum
um and then there's a dynamic
programming equation
and hence it you know as as you all know
okay um and q learning is all about
estimating this beautiful thing okay so
i told you i'm not going to use pi
i'm not going to you know use rewards
but
q is sacred you know we all know that
i'm not going to get rid of that
we are q all right that's that's sacred
and because you know one of the reasons
we want to get q is because
we get the policy but also because monte
carlo methods work so beautifully to
estimate q
so there's two reasons for estimating q
um and i'm not going to go through this
so if you want to
we've monkeyed around with some really
dumb culinary
problems for a helium ventilation system
i realize i don't have time to go
through it
but we just took the stupidest possible
setup taking a quadratic uh
a quadratic function of just arbitrary
state variable we just created a fake
state with forecasts
um a forecast of
cur a future humidity forecasts of
occupancy this junk
got a quadratic approximation for the q
function you know and it worked i took a
million
uh samples to make it work but it it
worked so
it's it's amazing how you could hack
away um
and and get things to work i just i just
love it so
but this is not for this audience you
guys have seen much more exciting
examples um i i will mention though that
this thing that we call zap cue learning
was the only thing that worked for this
example so
there's a challenge for some of you um
okay but so um so again
um i mean i'm not gonna go through that
but uh
so so we all know this uh dynamic
program equation and you all
most of you know how to go to to cue
learning
is exactly what you know you you look at
this function
you make a definition and you
you the magic is notation almost i have
an operator that takes any function of
two variables
to a function of one variables by taking
a minimum and you can see from this
dynamic program equation that the
minimum of q is just j
so you go from the fixed point equation
for j
to a fixed point equation for q
and thank you watkins you know
it's just it's just absolutely awesome
and
we get the minimum outside
you know here the minimum is
is i mean outside of of
of f
you know having this minimum
outside of this uh expression here makes
it using monte carlo methods very
difficult
and chris i guess chris watkins maybe
which suddenly had something to do with
it
the genius of introducing q function
is right there and as he pointed out
it all becomes um yeah i mean
they could be anything it all becomes
model
model free
you know this just absolutely wonderful
trick and you couldn't do this with this
representation up here
you know you wouldn't be able to get
this beautiful model free representation
of error
without this trick of going from the q
function
from the value function j to the q
function here
um and that really is is the
is the starting point of cue learning
algorithms um
and it's just wonderful um and so
i'll just say a few more words on this
so um
one thing one can do is
look at this again i've got this model
free representation
of this bellman error and one thing you
can do i want to try to make it
approximately zero on my observations
and you could look at the mean square
there's no problem with that
you know and you can do gradient descent
so there are some questions uh so first
question just clarifying is
everything deterministic here oh yes oh
yeah i forgot to mention that
so i i decided to give myself a
challenge
and make everything deterministic for
the entire day
so i'm going to relate things to
stochastic settings as well
but um but i'm going to try to argue
with you
if i have time that this makes sense
even if it's stochastic
it won't solve the problem exactly it'll
solve a different problem
but it's not a bad problem it depends on
how much volatility there is
yeah so yes all deterministic this whole
entire thing it will be deterministic
but quasi
sometimes i'll have randomness um like
sine waves things like that
quasi-quasi random numbers um that's how
you get away with this here
um it makes things so much easier to
explain so there it is
so i could i could have like something
you know rd where i have by
a stable feedback law plus uh a mixture
of sinusoids
right uh yeah and the question from
i mean i think it's for some earlier
slides
uh and it says the note that you
mentioned about the reference some call
it
active input right when z uh
desired uh at the next times is f times
desired yeah three times
times uh the input at time same time
step
it's been a while ago i think yeah it's
way back there
um no no i'm not sure it's worth it
we should
during the break okay um okay i think
it's going to be relevant
to the rest um but
you know you can do grading descent you
know and it works sometimes i mean i've
done grading descent
on on silly examples and it's been great
um and the my main point here is that
you go through and you look at an ode so
the entire the thing i'm going to be
pushing is this od method
every single lecture i'm going to be
talking about the od method
where you first look at i've got my
f which is my mean dynamics
which is minus the gradient of my loss
function
and first i look at the ode and say is
it stable is it doing what i want
and if yes then i go through and i
translate
and this is the definition of of
stochastic well i'm going to be calling
it qsa
the q stands for quasi the cause of
stochastic approximation
because everything is deterministic all
right
um and this works brilliantly sometimes
but it's a horribly non-convict function
awful so it's not convex so that's the
trouble
which is a big sad phase we'll fix it
next hour all right um and the
stochastic case you can't do this
to your question anonymous attendee um
you can't exactly do that because you if
you want to solve the problem
if you want to expect the equations you
can't square
the bill in error so what people do
is they do something that's called a
galerkin relaxation
or projected belmont error
those are the these are the two names
for it you stick
a a d dimensional vector z k
where if theta is is d dimensional
and you try to find the roots of this
function okay
that's that's really what q learning and
td linear
uh end up uh trying to do uh it's a
relaxation of the constraint
that you'd really like the conditional
expectation of this guy to be zero
uh with probability one all right and um
this zeta k is called the eligibility
vector
all right um and uh and
we'd like to set that to zero um
the uh design principles are the same if
you want to derive q learning
you basically can look at node e and if
you like
put in some matrix game and then you use
the euler scheme if you
if you like and you get an approximate
order scheme
and do just as i did before um you know
i mean i'll go back if you like
ah you do exactly the same thing you
know
you replace the mean object
with the observed samples you know
that's what it's all about
and so for q learning traditional q
learning it's not a gradient
it's so the eligibility vector comes in
instead
so if you'd like i'll write it down you
get theta n plus 1
equals theta n plus
alpha plus 1 again times the gain if you
want here
and then times this thing here this uh
this
zeta n times some um
dm dn i'll call it plus 1.
this whole thing would be called d n
plus one
the temporal difference
does that look familiar yeah it does yes
all right all right okay so that's
that's
that's it so where do we go from here i
have a minute right
i have 30 seconds so this is this is my
my sadness that i can't be in france
right now this would be
after you get out of the metro on your
way to india paris
you would you would see this this happy
woman and go around the corner and find
a way to india
in paris but i sadly i'm stuck here in
florida
um so the aspects they're really
big takeaways every control problem is
multi-objective
in terms of things you care about and
there's safety and robustness and blah
blah blah
i think that we're always going to have
historical business
you can have multiple control loops in
rl as well as in
traditional control it makes sense you
can
look do some micro controls to simplify
this system
on a macro level that's the example and
uh of course use a model if you if you
can
and uh test test test
um you know we all know that that's i'm
speaking to the choir
um so there's some other tricks of the
trade i didn't talk about control they
happen to functions
it's so close to rl it's ridiculous you
know
and um you know google it
model reduction techniques are a huge
part of uh
control it's like a big part and it's
been a big part of my own research
fluid models and this is all
this model reduction leads to methods
for future uh selection
so i want a basis for approximate q
function
gain insight from a naive model to do so
and of course midfield games are awesome
as well i won't get into that
this is just this is advertising
um so in terms of the next lectures just
real quickly
this this awful complex non-linear
bellman equation
that the lack of convexity i talked
about it's been a roadblock
buck forever the the
lp approach to uh optimal control has
been mentioned in previous talks
um that leads to q learning algorithms i
don't know why we don't use them so
that's the next lecture
i want to try to convince all of you to
always start with an ode
so no leonard no
this equation one should be a here's an
ode
with desirable properties how do we
design algorithms based on that
that should be this is step one
you design q oh i'm sorry use q
it's not my fault leonard used the queue
there um
you design a really nice od with really
good properties
and then translate it based on
observations and based on
your advice from your favorite numerical
analyst
that's lecture two i'm beginning the
next lecture
uh and finally grading free optimization
and and policy grading rl
and chava i'm going to give you the full
history on actor credit algorithms
uh in that lecture and so step one
od design step two
quasi stochastic approximation put in
some sinusoids or something
and then finally you do your order
lagrange and you oil the right holograms
or ring recruits or methods and you get
an algorithm you can put in a computer
that's what i want to sell today all
right
that's my sales pitch all right
um and uh and so this qsa
concept there it's way more reliable i
think than stochastic methods
when you have a control system that's
not that
volatile uh there's lots of uh theory to
explain why it's the way to go
all right um and uh that's it yep
and then of course there'll be a talk by
andre after that on
applications of similar ideas
yeah just just to play dabulous advocate
a little bit
of course i normally disagree with this
but
uh like it seems like an awful lot of
trouble to
uh start with a continuous time thing
and go
through all of these steps if at the end
of the day
everything happens in discrete time in
the computer
yeah yeah well well i'm going to i'm
going to try to sell this to you
as we go along it's definitely not the
easiest yesterday
because um yeah yeah yeah i mean it's
just that uh
yeah i'll give um
yeah oh i'll give examples
i'll give examples i'll give examples
where you could never come up with in a
way
unless you had an ode yeah you write in
some cases it would be
absurd you know there's no way you would
introduce td learning first as an ode
there's no way it's a waste of time you
know um
and um but i think but with culinary i'm
not sure
the od is so pretty you know you can
write down the od without all the
complete notation is so simple you know
um yeah so i don't know but you i mean
other exceptions
everything i say has an exception it's
not the only way to do things
yeah um but
yeah so do we do have uh end of the
question
q a um i i would just read it out is
there a way to
incorporate an abrupt skew learning or
crazy gradients in a way that makes up
for the changes in spectra decomposition
of the dining map and also
non-stationary stochastic error in
control oh my gosh okay
that's too much to unpack but but the
but i think that it's a i whenever i
teach to cast a control
i always say that rl sells itself
at being model free when i think it's
the biggest deficit of rl
you know that rl doesn't have the tools
to use a model if it had one i think
that's a deficit not
not a benefit i think there are cases
where it's a benefit i mean
there are cases where i believe so
strongly in that point of view
bandits chaba in bandits there's no way
there's a model
it's online learning the the that point
of view is so dead and correct
but in in autonomous vehicles where
i have so much structure and model uh
you know model uh model um properties
i'd love to be able to use that prior
knowledge
in the design of a reinforcement
learning algorithm and i think it's a
significant gap in the field
um i think again my ignorance is vast so
there's a lot of things i could be
missing but i think that's an exciting
challenge
so i guess uh there are some simple ways
that you can
combine learning and and similar
algorithms with model-based uh
learning right so rich saturn likes this
dyna architecture where you
simultaneously run a model
and then the model also generates extra
um data that is fed into your model free
argument
and so right like there are like some
obvious ways of doing these things
um it's not like that people didn't try
or
oh no oh no yeah sure sure no but
i'm just saying no no it's still a
frontier oh yeah of course i'm not
saying nobody thought
a good way or what's yeah anyways uh
renee carmona is asking uh why do you
bring up mean field games
oh it's so it was so it's it's
advertising uh uh
among um it was so much fun so
so so the control community is obsessed
with reduced order models and they they
come up with like a like i mean neat
field games
they come up with like a one-dimensional
model of an infi
of an infinite dimensional system and
they say my god success and they walk
away
uh and and basically this this is from
one paper where we basically took the
pre-limit
so this is so we we got the solution
from an infinite agent
limit and we looked at 10 agents
and we knew the structure of the optimal
solution at infinity
so we said well let's give each agent a
cue
a a q learning problem and they're all
going to solve
a q learning problem pretending that
they're at the infinite
limit and it worked perfectly
it just was crazy you know every agent
the parameters converge to exactly what
the infinite limit should should so it's
satisfying
um so this is a way we got structure
from our abstract model
and just it just solved a problematory
projectory problem but it was
it gave the architecture for the q
function approximations
um and this is a multiplayer game so
there's no way they'll be theory to
support it i don't think okay
yeah i'm glad you asked that thanks yeah
yeah all right but yeah but the whole
thing is model reduction and that's so
that was my point in both of those
okay i don't see any other questions uh
for now and we are right on time
uh
so this is uh good oh okay
some other question i arrows
so blue uh hi sean thanks for the talk
you use the word
gain in a few slides during this talk
and i've seen it all over the place in
contra
but i don't have any background and i
don't know what game is supposed to mean
game no no yeah oh when did i use that i
mean way back
in the beginning yeah like at the very
beginning i think uh
yeah why when you were talking about
oh yeah yeah yeah that's right okay okay
okay
so um lined up
the wind up the wind up i can't get into
it's basically
very often you're integrating
observations
um and when you integrate something it
tends to explode and people call it wind
up
but don't have a simpler thing where's
my where's my simple feedback loop right
here so
so i've got i've got measurements you
know
and then i have some sort of signal here
which leads to an error signal
right here and this compensator is often
very simple
simple uh an example of the com
of a um there's a u here an example of u
is just to take e plus some constant
i'll call it k sub i times the integral
from
well e sub u sub t
um and o i should put a k here as well
so k
p and k i are gains
so why do you integrate the error you
know you want the area to go to zero
you know so and so if you use
if you use just this uh proportional
control law
a well you're not going to kill the
error but if you integrate it
if that integrated remains bounded you
can
there's a lot of theory to say you
solved your problem the air goes to zero
but when these gains are large
it's it's like driving a car on after
too much coffee
just wham wham wham and if you
if you also have drunk too much there's
a delay you're unstable
so um
that increases the delay the delay plus
the high gain
you're unstable that's right that
probably killed you ah
don't yet okay so next question
uh so that relates to the end of the
talk uh jumping back and forth
uh do the convergence properties
translate to the stochastic case
uh yes yes yes the uh
the theory of stochastic approximation
is so complete it's crazy
you know and in the fact more cards
could have a new edition of this book
out
uh next year it's just there are so few
assumptions
needed to go from the ode to the sushi
caster approximation
it's really something you know um
so yes the answer is yes um you need
some moment downs etcetera things like
that
so out cut loud is asking the question
could you talk about your earlier
comment
on financial sector and rl was wondering
what
perspective of the our experience in the
financial sector was if you could have
yeah yeah yeah okay so i've met people
from the financier quite often and
there there's a there's rumors going
along in finance
that people in rl came along
and had no respect for learning about
you know
the issues in finance and this tried to
sell their algorithms
and it was all so this is just anecdotal
okay but
let me see a couple of people but but
but we're
firmly ingrained in morgan stanley
and other comm and a consulting company
and and basically said there wasn't any
interest in really learning about the
problems and issues
um and i think that i've seen i've seen
traces of that in papers
you know what is what's the proper
features for
wall street to solve a a problem on wall
street
think about how hard that would be
imagine just looking at stock prices
it's trump's tweets might be more
important than stock prices
uh it's a it's a damned heart problem um
and uh and you know and also there's a
lot of history and hacks
to uh come up with uh with tricks for
uh stock trading and and
that that might be inspiration for good
architectures for wall street but that
was also
apparently ignored you know again i i
know very little about finance i don't
i'm not the expert
this is not
but i think finance is a cool area i'm
not going to get into it but for some
people
i think there's a lot of low-hanging
fruits um
i don't see any more questions so let's
take a quick break and uh
we come back after the break how when we
back on is it just 10 minutes
uh no i think that it's half an hour
usually
yeah we come back at uh in in
27 minutes okay so one last question
what does tita represent
uh like on this one or this slide it'll
be anything
you know so so theta you know
you could have you uk equals some
parameterized policy you know that's a
possibility
or you could have your our friend q
theta of x u
you know there's this those are the two
examples
[Music]
okay all right see you soon all right